north korea has implied the most likely
way the objects could have arrived was
by balloon
defectors in south korea sometimes
release balloons carrying propaganda
messages that always anger the north
korean leadership
an emergency instruction has been issued
to vigilantly deal with alien things
coming by wind and to trace their source
including balloons in areas along the
demarcation line
south korea has dismissed the
possibility that balloons could be the
source
it is the common view of experts that
the spread of the infection through the
virus being carried on the surface of an
object is virtually impossible
the more likely cause of the outbreak is
thought to be from china with
restrictions on the border finally being
eased earlier this year to allow much
needed trade after being sealed since
the start of the pandemic
accusing the south of being the source
is politically convenient with a
conservative administration now in power
here which is viewed as being far more
unfriendly it also helps to shift the
blame at a time when the north is facing
multiple crises
without vaccines north korea has relied
heavily on promoting exercise homegrown
remedies and medicines to overcome the
outbreak
and with less than 5 000 new cases of
fever a day it seems to be over the
worst of it but there are also warnings
about an increase in waterborne
illnesses from abnormally heavy summer
floods which have damaged agriculture
and further adding to north korea's
ongoing food shortages
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul